personally I would say and this didn't
exist when I was younger it's not
necessarily a year out but spend some
time doing a lot of different jobs
because doing a lot of different jobs
you do find out what you don't like so
you could flip burgers for two weeks if
you wanted to learn the ropes of the
McDonald's trade then quit then go on to
your next job learn that job see what
you didn't like from it take the things
you did and then put them together in
the third job you go to so I think
taking a year away to find out what you
don't like is a great way to do things
and then if the choice is to go to
university because you want to be XYZ
that needs that then of course you go
but the problem with going when you
don't know what you want to do is that's
a lot of debt and that debt at some
Point's got to be paid off and you may
never go into that job or use that
degree ever again in your life so it is
a bit of a waste I think for a lot of
people
foreign